le gouvernement signaient une charte de
confiance ce matin avec les commerçants
spécialisés dans la vente sur internet
un secteur en perpétuelle croissance son
chiffre d'affaires annuel est estimé à
10 milliards d'euros
il y règne un certain désordre ainsi des
particuliers gros vendeurs finissent par
faire de ce loisir une activité
commerciale non déclaré anne bourse
virginie herz à 27 ans virginie et
guillaume sont à la tête de leur
entreprise un commerce de dvd et jeux
vidéo
un commerce qui réalise la moitié de son
chiffre d'affaires sur internet
leur aventure a démarré en 2003 à cette
époque ils travaillent tous les deux
dans les assurances
c'était avant tout pour hommes pour nous
faire plaisir au début et puis après au
bout d'un moment ça a été c'était
rentable donc du coup on faisait
l'événement donné pour revendre sur
internet et pour acheter de plus en plus
de six ans falloir acheter de plus en
plus de stock pour revendre et c'est
comme ça que ça a pris une ampleur a
fait à fait énorme en fait au départ ils
fréquentent les sites de vente en ligne
où tout le monde peut vendre n'importe
quel produit il réalise deux ou trois
ventes de dvd par jour puis rapidement
c'est une dizaine ils décident de créer
leur société en mai 2004
aujourd'hui virginie s'occupe à plein
temps des ventes sur internet
ça a été un tremplin on n'a pas eu
l'idée d'ouvrir un magasin pas faux part
on achète quelque chose d'accès internet
vraiment qui nous a permis de faire ça
progressivement la démarche de virginie
et guillaume n'est pas isolé
si au siège de ce site d'achat vente en
ligne le commerce entre particuliers est
toujours en pleine explosion
un internaute sur deux achète ainsi
l'entreprise incident les vendeurs
réguliers se déclaraient professionnels
quand on vend 300 euros d'articles par
mois c'est pas tellement différent dans
vingt-trois mille c'est juste une
question de temps qu'on y passe donc si
un particulier passe deux heures par
jour à faire 300 euros par mois ci
devient professionnel et qui travaillent
huit heures par jour mais il va assez
naturellement passé à plusieurs milliers
d'euros
et puis ensuite peut-être pouvoir
embaucher des gens qui vont l'aider à
vendre la frontière entre vendeurs
professionnels et amateurs est parfois
floue
on estime que plus de 15000 francs ça
tire une grande partie de leurs revenus
de cette activité un vrai réservoir de
création d'entreprise
en bref